the war in ukraine where russian forces
are shelling more targets in the crucial
eastern region known as donbas civilians
are fleeing some villages that are under
intense attack and the largest city
still controlled by ukraine in that
region could soon be under siege in the
south ukrainian forces are trying to
prevent russian russia from cementing
control there mts taeyab got rare access
to the front lines
we are on our way to a front-line trench
that is just two miles from where
russian forces are positioned
almost everywhere you look around here
the signs of war signs of devastation
this village was once home to three
thousand people
most of them have all left
apart from vossel who's lived here for
over 30 years and says he can't bring
himself to leave russian forces are just
a few miles that way
does that concern you
yes it worries me he says it's so
disturbing to see our village like this
as we make our way through a maze of
trenches we meet up with ukrainian
soldier artem who's been here since
march
we're getting used to it he says our
guys are tough and seasoned in battle
and we're holding our ground
because of security concerns we aren't
allowed to name this village or say
where exactly it's located beyond that
it's close to the curson region which
russian forces now occupy
well you might be able to hear the sound
of artillery
and
it really is
the sound of this area as we're shown a
bunker where ukrainian soldiers take
cover
more shelling
[Music]
this time outgoing
down below it may be grim and dimly lit
but for these battle weary fighters it's
a sanctuary from russian shelling and
where we meet the battalion's lead medic
there was so much shelling i mean are
you worried that russian forces could
take this village from you
that's why we're here he says to prevent
that from happening
it's a fight close to soldier andre's
heart he grew up near this area what do
you want russian people to know about
what's happening here in this village
where you're based
i would love them to wake up he says i
want them to realize where putin is
leading them
now a ukrainian court has just sentenced
a russian soldier to life in prison
following the country's first ever war
crimes trial since the start of the
invasion the 21 year old admits to
killing a 62 year old civilian but says
he was only following orders nate
mts i know your coverage can be
dangerous at times but these stories
need to be told so thank you so much for
what you're doing we appreciate you